bonjour Père Pedro bonjour ravie de vous
rencontrer vous publiez un livre c'est
le cinquième fruit de vos conversations
et Pierre Lunel sur votre vision de la
vie sur les valeurs que vous défendez ce
livre s'appelle résistent avec un point
d'exclamation alors pourquoi ce titre
c'est un ordre que vous nous donnez de
résister
un encouragement c'est un encouragement
et elle résister résiste ça veut dire et
courage de mettons des bouts on peut pas
laisser et on peut passer laisser écrasé
par les difficultés par la pauvreté par
par la maladie on est là si Dieu nous
donne vie esprit c'est pour se mettre
debout et voilà ça fait déjà des années
de des dizaines d'années que qu'on
résiste à Madagascar ça fait 50 ans ça
fait 50 ans 50 ans
vous êtes arrivés en 1989 vous êtes en
19 je suis arrivé 1970
vous vous êtes
slovène d'origine
argentin né en Argentine et en Argentine
vous arrivez à Madagascar et vous
découvrez cette décharge
c'est pas si vite que ça
décharge et la découverte 15 ans plus
tard
à 1989 et j'étais avant missionnaire
dans le sud-est là-bas il y avait il y
avait pauvreté les gens et c'est un
endroit très humide très beaucoup de
chaleur beaucoup de l'eau polluée je
voyais que de morts des morts des
enfants qui meurent qui meurent j'ai
demandé je suis pas venu ici
entre les gens et là ça m'a ça m'a
frappé alors on a travaillé on s'est mis
à horizé parce que là ça m'a choqué la
un enfant affamé un enfant qui a faim
j'ai claque je ne pourrais
pas rester tranquille il faut que je
fasse quelque chose donc vous avez écrit
cette association
akamasu mais c'était plus tard quand
j'ai des laissé la côte Est pour monter
à la capitale en Tananarive ou les gens
venaient chercher des travailleurs qui
n'ont pas trouvé et que c'était c'était
un peu après le le chacun se débroulé
comme il peut il s'en allait sur une
décharge et c'est déjà là il est habité
par des milliers de famille alors
et là quand j'ai vu c'est décharges là
c'était 1989 ça fait 33 ans je suis
resté tellement choqué je suis bien allé
trop choc je dis non on peut ici il faut
faire quelque chose
ce soir là c'est le début de cet
engagement qui dure déjà 33 ans
mais j'avais une expérience de
Madagascar depuis
1970 on a appris la langue on a pris les
traditions la mentalité et il faut
surtout la langue pour parler avec les
gens bien sûr avec les gens parce que
les gens quand vous êtes venus là-bas
c'est soit que je n'ai quand j'ai vu
cette séjour que j'ai vu c'est déjà et
le soir je pouvais pas dormir j'ai levé
les mains je dis je me suis agenouillé
sur mon lit je pouvais pas dormir c'est
des dieux aide-moi à faire quelque chose
pour ses enfants voilà le le démarrage
de de cet engagement auprès des gens de
la décharge et lendemain je suis allé
là-bas allez les voir il me dit blanc
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'est-ce que tu
cherches parler avec vous et moi on
parle et je dis on parle pas des bouts
des choses comme ça au milieu de la rue
Petit entrer dans cette case là un casse
d'un mètre 30 d'auteurs des cartons et
des plastiques je décide entre
je dis avec quel argent je vais aider à
ces 30000 personnes nous avons
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
18376 étudiants élèves à kamasu
dont 11000 de l'école primaire vont
manger à la cantine ça veut dire un bol
de riz tous les jours tous les jours
c'est nous devons acheter dix ans de riz
tous les semaines comment vous financez
ça c'est les bons dieux qui nous bon
Dieu vous aurez de l'argent mais moi ça
fait 33 ans que j'essayais la France
Nords de Noro Sud Ouest chaque fois
qu'un livre apparaît gestion la France
je témoigne et bon les gens les gens
participent et les gens
veulent aider quand ils savent que c'est
que ce qu'il donne arrive vraiment aux
pauvres que ce n'est pas détourné ils
veulent ils veulent aider et moi je veux
rendre honneur aussi à tous les
missionnaires religieuses
pasteur qui travaille en Afrique à
Madagascar qui sont au fond de la
brousse qui sont au fond de la forêt et
qui tiennent les gens debout avec
l'espérance qui sont inconnues à ces
gens-là aujourd'hui aussi je vais les
aider parce que j'étais dans cette
situation là pendant 15 ans personne ne
connaissait et j'avais des gens qui me
suivent et je pouvais pas les aider
vous disiez ce livre à toutes les femmes
du monde qui résistent pour leur liberté
pourquoi les femmes en particulier
pourquoi dédicacées
de Madagascar c'est les femmes qui qui
travaillent qui se dévoue pour leurs
enfants il y a tant d'hommes qui
laissent leur famille qui abandonnent
leur famille et là ça fait mal ça fait
mal nous à kamasu nous avons à accueilli
plus de 60% des femmes seules avec avec
5 6 7 jusqu'à 9 enfants et bon chaque
enfant c'est comme un petit ange et bien
nous les avons toujours accueilli
toujours je dis si Dieu existe s'il a
une maman qui cherche à kamasu une aide
qui dit recevez moi comment on va le
dire il n'y a plus de place il y a une
place il y a toujours une place la est
très grande malgré l'extraordinaire
enfin ce que vous avez réalisé etc la
misère existe toujours il faut y croire
et tout le monde ne vient pas vous voir
Madagascar Madagascar est plus grand que
la France bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
terre beaucoup de terre alors nous on
peut chercher des nouvelles paires et on
ne peut pas dire à une mère des familles
qui vous supplie des bousakillés les
enfants qui vous regardent avec les yeux
qu'est-ce qui va dire cet homme là
est-ce qu'il va nous accepter ou non et
c'est coéquipiers je suis fier heureux
d'avoir autour de moi plus de 750 et
coéquipiers tous madagascés 80% des
femmes 80% des femmes et pourquoi aux
femmes parce que les comme je dis nous
avons aussi deux carrières nous avons
deux carrés de Pierre nous avons fait un
trou énorme de plusieurs deux hectares
énormes de 45 mètres de profondeur qu'on
à la main on a utilisé c'est vrai la
dynamite pour les prêter mais après les
femmes ils ont porté sur leur tête
toutes ces pierres ces moellons toutes
ces gravillons sous leur tête pour les
sortir dehors ces femmes là ce sont des
saintes femmes les pour ces femmes là je
vais jusqu'au bout des mondes chercher
justice justice et gagner quoi 2 euros
par jour 2 euros par jour pour
travailler de la levée du soleil
jusqu'au coucher du soleil et quand je
vais dans la légère dans la carrière ou
dans la décharge il me salue avec un
grand sourire j'étais quelle force quel
courage pour ces femmes là je vais
jusqu'au bout du monde de demander
justice je ne demande pas malgré ces
merveilleuses réalisations la misère
existe toujours à Madagascar elle est
très très forte il y a des jours
j'imagine où j'ai découragé la misère il
n'y a pas de répit il y a pas de jours
fériés c'est comment on fait pour ne pas
être découragés
spirituelle c'est cette force de
l'esprit moi j'y crois un Dieu amour
j'ai j'ai depuis
abandonné parce que tout d'un coup il y
a des enfants qui crient qui me cherche
et comme ils sont des milliers mais
quand je vois un enfant qui vient vers
vous un souriant comment je peux le dire
laisse-moi je suis fatigué et j'en ai
marre j'ai jamais eu la tentation de de
laisser tomber à cause des enfants c'est
les enfants qui m'épousent qui veut
pousser
je suis je suis fier d'avoir des
coéquipiers tous Malaga si je dis 750
collaborateurs j'ai dit coéquipiers
parce que ce sont mes frères et sœurs et
bien
parmi eux déjà c'est les enfants que
j'ai vu à la décharge ou dans la rue
aujourd'hui ils sont des professeurs
de médecins donc c'est ces parcours là
qui aussi vous nourrissent
on a pris la bonne direction
à kamasu il y a trois critères pour
recevoir une famille il faut travailler
il faut éduquer les enfants scolariser
les enfants et accepter la discipline et
discipline communautaire qui se
eux-mêmes qui l'ont créé à quoi ça
ressemble cette discipline c'est dire
première loi n'est pas voler parce que
un pauvre il a tendance à voler il dit
j'ai rien je dois survivre ici on
travaille quand on travaille on a une
petite aide et ça me permet de me faire
vivre je ne vole plus je n'insulte plus
je ne frappe plus
son épouse
je scolarise mes enfants
j'ai j'ai je ne mens plus je ne me
bagarre plus et ce sont tous des lois
qui c'est eux-mêmes des ont créés et à
main levé et si si on brise ce règlement
il y avait il y avait de punitions par
exemple ça dépend si il a frappé sa
femme s'il a il devait monter une
centaine de moelleux de la carrière vers
le haut
on n'a pas très envie
alors voilà mais je vous dis que
Madagascar aussi il y a une grande
richesse Madagascar c'est pas seulement
la pauvreté qui saute aux yeux bien sûr
tous les gens qui viennent mais c'est un
pays formidable et la population
malheureusement la pauvreté les abîmée
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui ne peut
pas aller à l'école il y a c'est pas 25%
qui qui peut passer scolarisé la
malnutrition n'est toujours présent et
c'est extrêmement pauvreté a fait que
beaucoup de nos frères et soeurs ils ont
ils ont perdu les les vertus les
traditions Malaga si qui est en train de
qui est la solidarité
la solidarité ça c'est la richesse ça
c'est leur manière de vivre de
s'entraider mais c'est extraire abîmé
beaucoup mais nous revenons nous là dans
un monde où il y avait extrêmement
pauvreté où chacun pour soi où il y
avait bagarre violente aujourd'hui
et ça revient la solidarité revient
l'entraide et la joie de vivre la joie
de vivre c'est ce qui est vous frappe le
plus
de vivre et là nous avons aussi nommé ce
qui sont légendaires maintenant et
toutes les touristes qui viennent à
Madagascar je les invite pas il vient
tout seul je dis mais qui vous a invité
je dis c'est le bon Dieu alors il y a à
chaque messe le dimanche nous avons 10
000 personnes entre 8000 et 10000
personnes où les gens participent
chantent danse la messe dure trois
heures et les Français qui sont là ils
restent trois heures je dis mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites ça fait trois
heures que vous êtes là on a pas vu
passer le temps il dit si les messes
sont aussi joyeuses
nous nous évalu évangélise aussi votre
force c'est votre foi une fois chevillé
au corps depuis toujours c'est un homme
un homme que j'essaye de suivre de l'âge
de 6 ans
6 ans ma mère m'a communiqué cette amour
envers cet homme mon père la même chose
et cet homme a donné sa vie pour pour
ses amis pour ses frères il s'appelle
Jésus pour moi c'est les plus grands
révolutionnaires vous l'avez rencontré à
l'âge de 6 ans 6 ans et depuis je le
cherche toujours je le cherche toujours
j'ai parce que Dieu quand je pense le
trouver mais il est déjà plus loin et il
me fait marcher marcher tout le temps et
je veux marcher derrière lui toute ma
vie au service des plus pauvres dans le
livre vous dites je sens en moi une
telle force une force de Dieu c'est de
l'ordre de l'indicible on peut pas dire
ça on peut pas expliquer ça on peut pas
on me les voir moi j'ai les gens qui
viennent il y a touristes qui est venu
il m'a dit mon père vous n'avez pas dit
toute la vérité je dis quelle vérité
toute la vérité mais dis l'ampleur de
votre travail la quantité des gens que
vous aidez vous n'avez pas dit ça c'est
d'écouter c'est vous des demoiselles si
vous de témoigner mais c'est vrai que
c'est indicible ce qu'on vit là-bas
c'est un disciple venez et voyez comme
il a dit Jésus
venez voyez et alors qu'est-ce qui vous
surprend ou qui vous met en colère quand
vous allez quand vous venez chez nous en
Europe le contraste d'abord c'est la
lenteur administrative oui vous venez
pas les
gens ils ont faim tout de suite quand
j'ai je ne peux pas supporter qu'il y a
des gens qui font de la queue pendant
des heures quand je vois ça j'ai dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe si chacun machou
je dis pourquoi ils font la queue
s'il y a une seule personne je dis
mettez d'autres personnes
veut faire la queue attendre pendant une
heure
ensuite ici en France je vois les
décalage la différence c'est pas de 1 à
10 c'est un à 100 la différence de
niveau des vies de pouvoir d'achat alors
et pourtant ici je ne vois pas autant de
joie qu'à Madagascar vous devriez être
vous devrez tout sauter dans la rue vous
devrez tous vous embrasser tout le temps
dans la rue vous saluer ici par censé
salut moi j'ai envie de saluer quelqu'un
me dit mais quoi il est toqué mais alors
je ne peux pas les saluer mais je ne
regarde avec mes yeux si mais là-bas
dans nos villages on se salit tout le
temps on se salit on se sourit moi ma
main le soir j'ai mal à la main parce
que je salue des milliers de personnes
mais c'est ça qui fait une ambiance
bon on est tous
le même bateau et on va on progresse on
va on va se sauver tous ensemble et pas
chacun pour soi comment on peut vous
aider nous de France de Paris
Pedro ici en France par Pedro point fr
vous il y a là un site que vous pouvez
aider et il faut donner l'adresse
pardon.fr
et on peut faire des dons et nous aidons
à tous ceux qui ont besoin aujourd'hui
je suis les porte-parole pas seulement
des gens d'akamasu de tout Madagascar et
de tous les pauvres parce qu'il faut
aider tous les pauvres même ceux qui
sont en France en entrant ici je vis une
famille qui est là au côté du bus au
côté du bus à côté là à 50 mètres d'ici
en sortant je pense que j'ai les saluer
et j'ai donné quelque chose parce que
s'il y a des enfants aussi qui est là
alors je sais pas je pense qu'il y a des
solutions je n'ai pas des formules
magiques
on peut toujours aider merci Père Pedro
je rappelle le titre du de votre livre
c'est résiste cosini avec Pierre Lunel
c'est aux éditions du Rocher c'est la
fin de l'émission pour aujourd'hui
n'oubliez pas ce soir vous avez
rendez-vous avec le club Le Figaro
culture avec Jean-Christophe buisson je
laisse Jean-Christophe vous annoncer son
programme bonjour je vous donne
rendez-vous ce soir pour un nouveau club
le Fillon culture à 20h un club de fille
en culture a consonance musicale cette
semaine nous parlerons notamment de la
comédie musicale Starmania sa nouvelle
version qui se rencontre un grand succès
à la scène musicale à
Boulogne-Billancourt je demanderai aux
deux journalistes du Figaro que j'ai
invité de donner leur opinion sur cette
nouvelle version plus de 40 ans après
celle de Michel Berger et Luke Plamondon
nous évoquerons aussi cette provision de
livres écrit par des chanteurs ou sur
des chanteurs cet automne ce sera
l'occasion de parler de Neil Young de
Bono mais aussi d'Étienne Daho aussi
d'Alain Bashung et puis en première
partie d'émission pendant une longue
demi-heure une longue conversation avec
Vincent Delerm qui célèbre cet automne
les 20 ans de carrière et qui a cet
occasion publie ce double album comme
une histoire et sans paroles il nous
racontera un petit peu ça conception et
sa réalisation et surtout son
originalité Vincent Delerm une comédie
musicale délivre c'est le menu du club
le figaroculture ce soir
très beau programme alors soyez au
rendez-vous à 20h avec Jean-Christophe
buisson et son invité exceptionnel
Vincent Delerm c'est fini pour nous
aujourd'hui on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit c'est Claudia Cohen
qui sera au manette de point de vue je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée à
bientôt
[Musique]